[Music]
on this sunday night
holy smokes the american west coast
up in flames and their effect on air
quality the air we're breathing right
now is equivalent to smoking 20 packs of
cigarettes
it's hard to breathe in canada too
careless covet 19
attitudes what critics say the
government needs to do about it
honoring aline [ __ ] the former prime
minister's most trusted confidante
and nellie carlson's a relentless fight
for equality
she's a little dynamite setting the path
for future indigenous generations
global national with robin gill
today is not a day to be outside on the
west coast
this is the afternoon sky in vancouver
the mountains and skyline are
shrouded in smoke and there isn't a
glimmer of sunlight
to be seen good evening and thank you
for joining us
the wildfire emergency in the united
states has created a hazardous situation
for people living in british columbia
environment and climate change canada
has issued air quality advisories for
much of the province
but the health risk is highest
throughout southern bc
people with respiratory and heart
conditions as well as those with
diabetes
are being told to avoid or reduce
outdoor activities
the same goes for pregnant women infants
children
and older adults there are also concerns
for the well-being of homeless and
socially marginalized people
who may not have adequate shelter
the health risks in western canada are
serious and in the days ahead
other parts of the country could be
affected by the smoke but south of the
border the emergency
is far worse at least 33 people have
died and that number
is likely to rise as mike delay reports
in our top story tonight
the environmental disaster won't get any
relief until the rains arrive
the sun may be shining on the u.s west
coast but few have seen it through the
thick black smoke
that has blotted it out a horror
horrible you don't know whether your
home is going to be there when you get
back
more than 100 fires up and down the
coast continue to set records
last week alone oregon saw double the
area burn that it normally sees in a
year
and three of the five largest wildfires
in california history
are burning right now you know this
thick smoke coming up from oregon
washington in california
is is essentially relentless at this
point the winds are pushing the smoke
inland
and north into canada in parts of
british columbia the air quality index
is at its maximum the smoke so thick
it's as if the fire is burning nearby
bc and alberta have been affected the
most but the sheer size of the smoke
field threatens to make this
a national event starting tomorrow uh in
a in a substantial way you know making
its way through southern saskatchewan
possibly as well affecting manitoba
ontario and even
in the pacific northwest officials admit
they won't be able to contain the fire
until the winter rains arrive in the
meantime it's an environmental disaster
that is set to become a political flash
point
when president donald trump who denies
climate change as a factor in the fires
visits california on monday it's about
forest management
and other things but forest management
trump will tour some of the disaster
zones but all eyes will be on how or
if he's received by california's
governor this is a climate damn
emergency
and los angeles mayor who said on cnn
when he needs advice on matters of
science
he doesn't listen to the president talk
to a firefighter
if you think that climate change isn't
real and it seems like this
administration at the last vestiges of
the flat earth society of
this generation causes aside what the
west coast needs right now
is help microlight global news
the southern u.s is bracing for a
possible hurricane
as tropical storm sally gained steam it
soaked parts of florida with about 300
millimeters of rain
that led to flash flooding in miami and
the surrounding areas
sally is now moving into the warm waters
of the gulf of mexico
and is expected to approach land late
monday bringing a powerful storm surge
with it a hurricane warning is in effect
for a stretch of the louisiana coast
including new orleans mandatory
evacuation orders have been issued in
some areas
this is peak hurricane season in the
atlantic look at all the systems out
there
including hurricane paulette it's a
category one storm that is expected to
strengthen
as it moves toward bermuda tomorrow
to the pandemic now and a snapshot of
the daily new case numbers in this
country
atlantic canada and the territories have
no new cases to report tonight
bc and alberta will have their weekend
tallies tomorrow
but for the third day in a row ontario
has reported more than 200 cases
quebec has the biggest spike with 279.
that's quebec's largest single day
increase in more than three months
canada's chief public health officer is
again reminding canadians
not to get complacent part of the
problem is that some people just don't
care
mike armstrong explains why and what
researchers want governments to do
to shift attitudes who lives here
this video may be the perfect example of
young people
and indifference towards kovitt 19. if
you have eight people in the house
that means you can really only have two
people over yeah it was a police officer
in ohio breaking up a small house party
on a university campus
the students were breaking the rules
having too many people at the home
you might want to start clearing them
out man that's fine please
but when the officer pulled up
information on one of the occupants
is that can you come here he found
something shocking
there's a i've never seen this before
there's an input on the computer that
you tested positive for covid
yes when was this this was a week ago
are you supposed to be quarantining yeah
that's why i'm at my house as it turned
out
several people in the home had tested
positive for covid 19
and were still having people over so
you're not quarantining if you're mixing
with other people
okay so everybody here has it oh my gosh
now that sort of disregard fits
perfectly with a new study by quebec
researchers
fifteen hundred people were polled they
found young people are less scared of
the potential consequences of covid19
and less likely to follow safety
protocols what was surprising
was that young people were also most
likely to overestimate their chances of
contracting the virus
many think they're going to get it and
still don't follow protocols
they are very well aware of what they
are doing and the consequences
on their own risk to contract covet 19.
that's one of the reasons the
researchers say governments can't only
focus on a medical response to the virus
whether it's targeted advertising or
fining rule breakers
the social side to changing attitudes
and actions
is vital the disease spreads because of
our behavior
so it's not only a medical problem but
it's a problem of the society
now there was another group that stood
out in the study as less likely to
follow directives
men compared to women they're less
likely for example to wash their hands
or if they do to wash them well so who
all lives here another example where a
cavalier attitude
can have consequences mike armstrong
global news
montreal the wife of former prime
minister jean-clay chen
has passed away alinkhreichen died
peacefully saturday morning
surrounded by family in her quebec home
she rarely spoke in public but behind
the scenes she was her husband's most
trusted confidant
advising him on key decisions in the 40
years of his political career
including the quebec independence
referendum in 1995.
that same year she helped save the prime
minister's life after coming face to
face with a knife-wielding intruder
who had broken into their ottawa
residence alincrechen came from humble
beginnings in set her future husband on
a bus
when she was 15 years old they married
six years later
and celebrated their 63rd wedding
anniversary this week
the cause of death has not been made
public alin kreichen
was 84 years old in less than 24 hours
polls will open in new brunswick in the
first provincial election
since the start of the covet 19 pandemic
a record number of people has already
voted
but the rest of canada will be watching
to see how election day plays out
and whether the risk of running a
campaign during a pandemic
can pay off politically ross lord
reports
new brunswick's election campaign is a
bit shorter than most
28 days but it will be remembered for
another distinction
i mean it's certainly a first with the
pandemic
and i mean you know i guess they had no
other choice if they couldn't come up
with a deal
together so you know we'll see who
who gets a majority or if it's another
minority pc leader blaine higgs is
riding a wave of popularity
from his government's success against
covet 19. going into the weekend
new brunswick had only two active cases
and just two deaths
since the pandemic started a former
irving oil executive
higgs is haunted by controversy after a
botched attempt to cut health care
services in rural areas
liberal leader kevin vickers is a former
sergeant at arms in the house of commons
he's best known for helping stop the
2014 parliament hill terrorist attack
vickers is making his first attempt at
public office
among the big campaign issues is the
question of whether the time is right
for an election
that was a bit of a shock you know i
thought was it really necessary the
pandemic we don't know how long it's
going to go on we have to be realistic
and with the knowledge that life goes on
politics goes on
election planners say turnout at advance
polls was extremely high
and there's been a big increase in the
number of mail-in ballots
officials believe that's a sign new
brunswickers want to
sidestep election day crowds and limit
any possible exposure to the virus
i think it's been pretty cordial
everybody has agreed to play by the
rules wear masks not hold large events
not have big barbecues and free hot dogs
public opinion polls
suggest higgs might indeed increase his
party's share receipts
possibly to 25 or more which would boost
the pcs
into a majority ross lord global news
fredericton new brunswick
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent david aiken david this
election is a test for pretty much any
future election in this country given
we're in a pandemic
how will this health crisis affect the
results
yeah i think this is a referendum
essentially on an incumbent
who wants some political stability as we
get into economic recovery mode and this
is an incumbent blaine higgs and the
progressive conservatives
that have a minority government right
now in new brunswick and so blaine higgs
has called an early election to say
to his voters let's have a referendum on
how i did on the health crisis
and how we should do in the economy and
you know what look around the country
right now
in bc robin premier john horgan a
minority government
voters in bc give him good marks on
handling the health crisis
does he call a fall election again
seeking some stability
saskatchewan scott moe they're going to
have an election there this fall
it's probably going to be a referendum
on health and economy and of course
think about the federal government
situation the trudeau minority
government will face some confidence
votes this fall
but again if voters have on them on
their minds it's a referendum on how you
did
through the health crisis and how you're
about to do through economic recovery
maybe opposition politicians don't want
that election
anyways new brunswick is where we're
going to test this team out first
and this is the first election in this
country where candidates had to conduct
a
contact-less campaign yeah it's been
really interesting so elections new
brunswick is quite prepared
they're taking steps to make sure that
their own workers in polls are safe
that voters can be safe if they go to
the polls but get this advance voting
is up 50 percent compared to 2018.
now as far as the parties go they've had
to figure out how to find voters
voter id get out the vote without doing
all the door knocking you normally do
and without those big fundraising
rallies it's been a very different
campaign as everybody figures out how to
do this
there's been a lot of use of technology
to track voters
and get voters out to the polls and here
we are on the eve of election day
did uh premier higgs gamble pay off
it looks like it's going to all the
polls we've seen shows the pcs
still have a bit of a an edge the gap is
narrow though between the liberals and
the pc so we'll see
one thing that has been consistent
throughout the campaign is the green
party is polling
above their 2018 uh levels of support
they're doing very well
and that could be a factor the greens
could pull away some support from the
liberals that would help the pcs
in any event this part of the country is
uh where the greens seem to be doing
best they have three seats
that's the same as in bc could they get
more tomorrow
it's going to be an interesting race all
right thanks for your analysis david
aiken and ross lord will be part of our
decision new brunswick special coverage
tomorrow night
you can watch it on globalnews.ca on the
global tv app
and on television for viewers in
atlantic canada
coming up the trump campaign ford is on
despite admitting he
downplayed the pandemic and why israel
is heading into
another lockdown
when it comes to covet 19 the u.s still
has the world's most cases
and the most deaths but american voters
won't be hearing donald trump talk about
the coronavirus on the campaign trail
jennifer johnson explains what trump
wants his fans to focus on instead
as he faces a firestorm of criticism
over the way he downplayed the pandemic
i've spent the last four years bringing
our jobs back to america
securing our borders rebuilding our
military
u.s president donald trump selling
voters on his record before the coven 19
pandemic
swept across america few in the tightly
packed crowd in nevada were wearing
masks
as the president claimed his democratic
opponent joe biden's plan to fight the
crisis
is a threat to civil liberties want to
lock law-abiding americans in their
homes which is what they're doing
and they want to keep them out of church
they really do they're fighting god
president trump is facing severe
backlash after admitting to journalist
bob woodward on tape in early february
he downplayed the virus i wanted to
[Music]
i wanted to always play it down i still
like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic this is deadly stuff
woodward on cbs's 60 minutes says the
president told him
he knew the virus was maybe five times
more deadly than the flu
this is the tragedy president of the
united states has a duty to warn
the public will understand that
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden is blaming the president for
millions of americans sickened by the
virus
and nearly 200 000 dead he lied to the
american people
he knowingly and willingly lied about
the threat it posed to the country
for months many medical experts say the
president should have been honest
about the need to prepare for the covet
19 threat
telling the truth never causes panic if
you just tell people the truth they will
respond and they will trust you
to continue to tell them the truth the
great leaders of the world have done
that
the pandemic taking center stage as
medical experts warn the death toll
will continue to rise before election
day
jennifer johnson global news washington
one time democratic presidential
candidate michael bloomberg is shelling
out some major cash
in hopes of getting joe biden into the
white house bloomberg is spending as
much as a hundred million dollars on
biden's campaign in florida
recent polls show trump and biden are
neck and neck in the sunshine state
voters there can start mailing in
ballots at the end of the month
still ahead as the pandemic continues
another country heads back
into lockdown
you're watching global national
a freak sandstorm darkened midday skies
near turkey's capital
a time lapse shared by the city's mayor
shows massive
dust clouds engulfing nearby buildings
officials say six people were injured
by the strong a winds thousand
protesters gathered in the capital of
belarus today in one of the biggest
demonstrations
yet demanding the country's longtime
ruler quit
[Music]
anger is not letting up protests have
been sweeping the country
since last month's contentious election
handed alexander lukashenko a landslide
victory
and a sixth term in office thousands of
people have been detained
at least three people have been killed
and hundreds hurt
as police break up the crowds the
opposition claims the vote was rigged
and key figures have since been jailed
or fled the country
israel's government is reimposing a
covet-19 lockdown
to contain a surge in cases the
three-week shutdown will start friday
which is the start of the jewish holiday
season
people will have to stay within 500
meters of their homes except to go to
work
and exercise schools restaurants and
non-essential shops will be closed
the decision has divided the nation
grappling with recession
israel is the first country to order a
second nationwide lockdown
up next the remarkable life of
indigenous advocate
nelly carlson
[Music]
montrealers did their part today to help
those who most need it by leaving
non-perishable items on their doorsteps
for food banks to collect
food banks across the country have seen
an increased demand
since the pandemic started there are
some causes that are too great to stop
fighting for alberta's nellie carlson
knew this well
she spent decades battling for rights
for indigenous people
her sheer will power was her greatest
weapon in the wake of her passing this
week
jamie dahl looks at carlson's remarkable
journey
it's pretty hard on me and pretty hard
on the children too i imagine because
she was the head person
she had a grade 8 education was a
residential school survivor
a champion for change she's a
little dynamite with a real sense of
humor a
ready wit fun to be around
but she really when she says something
she means it nellie carlson passed away
at the age of 93 in edmonton on thursday
her legacy as long and as full as the
life she lived
as was her humility what did i do
yeah this was just only the journey of
my life what i
did it didn't cost me nothing
but it sure made a massive impact on so
many lives
nellie was cree and 73 years ago she
married a metis man elmer
in doing so she lost her aboriginal
status when we
first married that was
about two weeks later she said she got a
letter from the government
telling her she was no longer an indian
she which hurt her very much
you know that really hurt her
and she fought for her status
for the next 17 years the mother of nine
never stopped fighting she was
instrumental in changing the indian act
and restoring indigenous rights to
generations of women
her fortitude inspiring many and this
edmonton school on sacred indigenous
land
bears her name keeping her legacy alive
the kids
loved having her here she stood up for
equity for equality for human rights she
stood up
for the rights of women in general and
she was also very committed to the whole
idea of education
carlson was honored to have a school
named after her
and she leaves this message for all
those young minds
inside i hope that uh
they were they're going to be blessed
with good ideas it was an idea i guess
maybe that i really had in my head that
i just used it jamie dog global news
calgary and that is global national for
this sunday
i'm robin gill we leave you tonight with
a tribute to terry fox
google is running a special illustration
depicting him during his marathon of
hope
in 1980 when he set off on a run across
canada to raise money for cancer
research
because of his own fight with bone
cancer which led to his leg being
amputated
four months into his fundraising effort
fox had to stop
because the cancer had spread to his
lungs he died the next year
today marks 39 years since the first
terry fox run was organized in his name
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back here tomorrow and i'll see
you next weekend
have a great night
[Music]
you